hmm yeah welcome to this video oh it's a
good idea to not totally screw up your
the order on your desktop as I just did
right before starting a video you the
bishop in a five-line yes this is a
viable line it's not particularly great
but also not not totally unplayable
White has a slight edge but and then
said it's not not the end of the world
yeah bishop affords a little trick black
takes Queen B seven wins the rook in the
corner yep keep that on the board and
going for before soon I just one down
Drago Queen a for Queen a four and then
maybe then b4 b5 not sure about the best
move water I have to move the Queen
again yeah p5 has already rather serious
threat so he has to do something like
this okay k exposure tix he wants to if
possible trade and trade of all the
nights
unsure if I should go to see one or not
take your money for of course what's an
option as well
maybe I shouldn't have gone Queenie for
but draw the Queen D 1 so that I had a
form i was thinking that maybe I have
night ok um and I thought I maybe have
them 90 to be 3a five things what is he
doing here really you can play like that
so it's surprising
you're first starting with a very
passive opening actually it's it's
passive I mean it's solid it's still
passive her black and then he pushes all
the points forward not quite not quite
sure what the idea is there Knight d2
yeah let's do that
I want it trade that night and also have
firm ok so it gives up this pawn of
course the H file is open that it is
clear so there might be some sort of
compensation but I don't really see
black coordinating that quickly how is
he here getting the Queen there some
something with King kinky of several end
and something like that maybe and I 2d
five-a-side yeah okay I wanted to play a
f3 anyway
yeah let's go let's go for that Queen a
night be 95 queen bee three I guess
covering III and getting the Queen Ian
into play my queen is really not well
placed this is sam this is an issue okay
i'm taking to go from there Bishop c4
was one idea Bishop c4 I should see for
then how can I did too but I don't know
how dangerous this is
I can also just do this I don't really
see a drawback to that move
have to watch the time a little bit bit
down
yeah he still had doesn't have the Queen
and the a drum playing so I don't really
believe in this this kind of attack and
then queen d 74 attack on d4
quick eh this is that this is a problem
that's a real problem okay
I already have to get my queen back here
to be three or something I'll see to
check
counter taking only 627 probably not
sure what my response to that is wow wow
okay I don't mind to return stuff Queen
f4 maybes edible but yeah yeah five I
mean a counter ticking and t5 fizzles as
well
time warning
communis is just one check right
Rock h1 King f2f1 Luke f1 quindi a
droopy one now I don't I don't believe
it black resigns yeah so it's plus a
million now I was very tough I mean I
have a hard time to believe in in this
kind of play but it's definitely
difficult difficult to fend off in an
actual game and take stakes and the five
Karen the NGO just gives me a small edge
and here in fact like it's good after
king of seven king of seven Quincy area
well he wants to do what i thought i
would do like f3 and stuff but this was
my idea he can take 1 h 2 now already
that's very very strong Jay for this
move very strong like winds immediately
so after King our seven have to start
with this and after this go F 3 I mean I
thought I wanted to go a three earlier
but that wouldn't have worked Knight f6
and queen edge Sonya that is that is
very dangerous the engine with this
currently with this current depth is
giving 0 maybe seeing some kind of
Perpetual check man that looks very
dangerous for white very dangerous f-35
lucky one yeah the engine approves and
says equal after this
check equal you had some kind of draw
probably but the engine is seen that
check keeley so here and now i went
there and for ya look h8 is the right
move via f4 looked wrong to me it looks
especially slow look h8s engine move and
it wants to check check and do this
equal equal it probably sees some kind
of Perpetual again it is very dangerous
and now here the snow is a window right
1.5 1.7 maybe yeah yeah I'm winning over
36 the other a tough game very tough
game I couldn't really believe that
sacrifice but it was definitely
interesting from a practical point of
view okay well thanks for watching